ou est ce qu'on est on est en extérieur
premier bon point pour vous avez gagné
deuxième bon point je vous donne dans le
mille on est à barcelone on est là pour
le mwc le gros salon la téléphonie
mobile salon international qui a lieu
depuis 2019 et ça c'est rien il faut le
dire donc là c'est vachement bien et on
est là pour parler de qui pour parler
d'eux au nord au nord qui m'a invité
gentiment voyage de presse avec plein de
journalistes est très chouette pour
venir présenter leurs nouveautés alors
il ya plein de nouveautés il ya deux
smartphones il ya le honor magic quatre
professionnels quel modèle qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui est qu'on présente
et vous avez également le honor magic
capter un peu en dessous mais qui est
aussi plutôt intéressant en tout cas sur
le papier et puis vous avez des
écouteurs une montre mais ça qu'on se le
garde parce que c'est parce qu'on va
regarder aujourd'hui alors qu'est ce qui
est cool et bien c'est que au nord il
montre les muscles mais comme ça enfin
peu plus que moi il montre les muscles
il montre de la performance sa dragonne
nuit jonone ils vont également montré de
la performance en photo dans c'était
marrant parce que pendant la conférence
de presse ils ont comparé tout le temps
leur smartphone iphone tu réponds dax
regardez on est mieux que on est mieux
que sur le papier ce intéressant mec
c'est du marketing ils le font et puis
bien évidemment plein de d'innovation
plein de technologie ism montre et on va
vous protéger votre sécurité lors de vos
appels pour que personne ne puisse
entendre on vous permet de faire de la
vidéo en flash qualités professionnelles
avoir effectivement si on est amené à
tester si c'est le cas ou pas peut-être
peut-être pas en tout cas voilà ils
viennent il montre les muscles agréé
smartphones qui est intéressant donc
aujourd'hui on fait quoi et bien on va
pas les manches et une barbe à papa sur
le port bien qu on pourrait mais c'est
pas le but aujourd'hui on fait quoi
aujourd'hui on va les découvrir ses
smartphones et notamment le procès le
modèle qui m'intéressent on va regarder
à quoi ressemble comment il est fait
qu'elle promet s'il fait et ça c'est
bien alors on y va
alors qu'est ce qu'ils nous proposent au
nord magic 4 au niveau design m'a déjà
on le voit c'est une vraie symétrie
enfin vrai me direz-vous si on voulait
une vraie symétrie alors émis au centre
et il serait qu'ils auraient plutôt
rectangulaire ça c'est clair mais par
contre si vous le coupez en deux là vous
avez un vrai fait symétrique est très
sympa alors la couleur qu'on a ici je
crois que c'est ma préférée celle ci ans
elle a plusieurs intérêts déjà c'est
qu'elle est un peu moins réfléchissantes
que les deux cas - cet effet miroir vous
avez des petits côté un peu alvéolé que
je trouve vraiment très très joli donc
ça c'est assez sympa on voit ce gros
module photo on se regarde le détail
dans quelques instants on a ici sur le
côté un petit bouton pour venir
l'allumer et l'éteindre en rouge là
c'est sympa ici le bouton de volume de
la recharge en usb c'est ça on s'en
doutera vous avez si un petit haut
parleur un micro et puis tiroirs de
karting avec double carte microsd 5 g si
on a des crampes surveillants des
créatures 26,81 pousser une techno ltp
oled alors ça permet quoi la techno ltp
oled est bien c'est d'avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement variable regarder je
vais essayer d'en fréquence de
rafraîchissement l'écran donc là je vais
venir switcher entre du 1 à 120 hertz en
fonction des besoins si je suis en train
de jouer un jeu et que j'ai besoin d'en
haut taux de rafraîchissement je vais
arriver directement 100 verte sinon si
je regarde une vidéo je serai en 25
images par seconde ou alors carrément je
vous dis ben tiens je voudrais féliciter
maximale jeudi sans relâche tout le
temps j'appuie là par contre l'autonomie
ça va baisser légèrement soit je me dis
je me mens 90e pour certains médias
pourquoi pas ou alors carrément très
standard en 60 hertz le mieux est ce que
je vous conseille en tout cas ce qui me
semble être intéressant et on verra si
on est amené à le tester ces dix mètres
en dynamique comme ça il va dire
switcher lui automatiquement escale et
sur les besoins réels que vous allez
avoir une résolution de 2848 par mille
trois cents à quatre cents 60 images par
seconde 1 milliard de couleurs un espace
colorimétrique 100% dci p3 un écran
certifié hdr 10 plus et on va aller
jusqu'à un pic de luminosité milite
salle hors sac là sur un salon seront
absolument pas compte parce qu'il est
lumineux ou pas il est lumineux mais à
l'extérieur je vois quatre cas sur le
papier c'est ce que nous annonce au nord
on peut aller jusqu'à 1000 litres et un
truc intéressant si vous allez avoir un
obscur ling votre contenu va succi du
sdr vers le hdr et puis un gros travail
qui a été fait pour réduire toute la
fatigue oculaire au niveau de ce
smartphone et si vous voulez jouer et
bien vous avez un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile qui va jusqu'à 360 r au niveau
logiciel on tourne sur magic rawhi 6.0
qui est basée sur l'android 12 alors mec
du coin ça fonctionne c'est bien c'est
pas la meilleure expérience que je
connaisse mais en tout cas sur android
mais malgré tout retrouver facilement
tout ce que vous voulez votre écran
d'accueil vos fonds d'écran on peut
switcher votre son vallières planquer le
petit module photo dont je vous parle
dans quelques instants voyez il vient
complètement invisible et puis comme on
les sent drôle elle en plus eh bien ça
vient économiser la batterie donc ça
c'est plutôt intéressant également après
on trouve vraiment les fonctionnalités
principales 1 qu'on attend d'un
smartphone ici les cas ce que ça raconte
au niveau de l'audio la sarre à contes
qu'on a des haut parleurs stéréo fait
normal alors il faudra une fois de plus
venir le tester pour vraiment voir
l'expérience et si c'est pas forcément
très très simple on a du bluetooth 5.2
pour venir à péret des écouteurs sans
aucun problème et il nous propose en
enregistrement 24 bits hdr avec trois
micro stéréo alors peut-être que si vous
voulez vous enregistrez qu'on puisse
voir un peu la spécialisation aller
coûte ça peut être intéressant à voir
également au niveau des usages et le
truc qui coule c'est la performance
qu'est ce que nous on dit ici et bien on
a un processeur le plus performant
actuellement c'est à dire à sa dragonne
8 john wayne de première génération
c'est le processeur qui était présenté
par qualcomm fin d'année dernière à
white ou des vosges vous avoir mené
c'est très sympa et en plus on a un
combo soit 8 gigas de ram soit 12 giga
de ram et entame de stockage cdu 256 ou
512 les jca de stockage pour la version
professionnelle et si vous êtes sur la
version non pro vous commencez à 128 go
de stockage mais aujourd'hui ce qui nous
intéresse c'est quoi ses plus hauts de
gamme ces modèles pro alors aux
satellites pour vous parler de la charge
il fallait changer un peu on vient
l'extase comme ça on peut enlever le
masque ils ont fait un truc qu'il
vachement bien une fois de plus dans
l'idée de montrer les muscles c'est
qu'ici vous avez une batterie de 1600
millions pérore me direz-vous ok c'est
bien monsieur gros mais c'est par le
truc le plus fou du monde c'est vrai
mais là où ils ont fait un truc
absolument dingue c'est déjà ils vous
ont fait de la recharge filaire 100
watts quand je fais 100 watts je joue en
même temps sur mes cuisses mais ils ont
fait également de la recharge sans fil
sans voix c'est dur à dire il ya
beaucoup de s mais je dis alors regardez
j'ai des chiffres assez lire on a déjà
de la recharge sans fil il ya du vent ça
bouge au papier vous le recharger
jusqu'à 60 % en seulement 15 minutes
rendez vous compte c'est absolument
dingue et vous le recharger à 100 % en
30 minutes et c'est vachement
intéressant pourquoi parce que en fait
aujourd'hui la question l'autonomie va
de moins en moins se poser au niveau des
smartphones on va pas se dire est ce que
je peux le garder un jour un jour et
demi deux jours vous pouvez bien
évidemment avec une seule charge mais on
s'en fiche ce qui est sûr c'est que vous
le preniez même si vous vous levez le
matin qui vous reste 20% et bien le
temps de vous faire un café vous le
branchez vous repartez pour un jour un
jour et demi très facilement que tant de
vous brosser les dents d'aller vous
l'avez si vous vous l'avez d'ailleurs le
conseil vous le faites très rapidement
pour qu'on veut plus se poser la
question de l'autonomie alors on voit
que les marques elles vous disent on
fait de la sao en réalité c'est pas de
là sans voix tout le temps vous allez
pas le chargé de zéro à cent pour cent
ans en boîte vous avez un pic en 100
watts et après ça va redescendre
probablement perdu 65 watts après perdu
45 entre préfectures du 25 watts on
finira une petite charge toute douce
faire du 15 mai pour venir protéger
votre batterie mais ce qui est bien
c'est côté rassurant parce qu'on va loin
le mal l'autonomie donc ça ça me plaît
côté photo vidéo ils ont vraiment mis le
paquet premier cap tà capteur principal
c'est un grand temps que de 50 méga
pixels touvre f 1.8 et puis vous avez
également un ultra grand-angle toujours
de 50 méga pixels couvre f 2.2 avec un
champ de vision de 122 degré et puis
regardez il est là juste au centre c'est
votre télé objectifs avec un zoom
périscopique le capteur cdu 64
mégapixels et on peut aller d'un zoom x
035 en optique jusqu'à zone x 100
faut-il pour autant aller au poisson la
réponse est non mais si vous voulez vous
pouvez vous avez également un capteur
tough qui vous servira pour vos mots de
portraits notamment et puis vous avez
une caméra de cette fille de 12
mégapixels avec le champ de vision 100
degrés je vous montre ça c'est
intéressant plus un capteur 3d qui va
permettre notamment d'avoir un
déverrouillage spatiale plus sécurisé sa
cette rue qui est intéressant sur la
caméra de self y regarder c'est que là
je suis en foin c'est normal mais
derrière vous le voyez ya les eaux qui
est en train de filmer et on veut qu'il
soit vraiment dedans donc la page
j'appuie l'afp à 120 08 je suis sur un
os sion d'ultra grand temps que c'est
intéressant mais si je me donne encore
deux trois potes à la fête et que l'on
va aller un peu plus loin des regards
des jeux ras puis la paf long et en
large et là je peux emmener du monde
dans l'histoire donc ça c'est
intéressant et puis lorsqu'on switch de
l'autre côté on est sur notre caméra
principale si on veut avoir un peu plus
de monde tac on passe sur large alors je
trouve un peu déformant sur les côtés
mais ça faudra le voir effectivement si
on est amené à le tester et puis après
on peut aller plus loin garder en x 3 05
et puis là c'est là où ça devient la
folie absolue on va jusqu'en fois sans
alors là vous me direz devant moi il n'y
a pas grand chose mais je peux aller la
chercher des images très très très très
très très très très très loin regardez
là par exemple on a le logo nord
bellemare donc bon faut-il pour autant
et jusque là je ne pense pas mais en
tout cas il se peut que jusqu'à un zoom
x 30 ce soit convenable une fois plus
faut le voir info le tester donc comme
ça un peu compliqué de vous dire mais en
tout cas voyez ils ont vraiment fait le
choix de vouloir montrer les muscles dix
ans on peut aller jusqu'à vingt fois
cent nous aussi il n'y a pas que samsung
et son space zoom on n'est pas là non
plus pour ce match donc ça c'est
intéressant alors y'a un truc sans
qu'elle bosse au nord et qui as
intéressant c'est un mode film en plus
du mode vidéo vous allez pouvoir venir
filmer en flat c'est à dire avec des
notes ou une colorimétrie l'image donc
soit sur du classique alors après vous
avez de l'éclat du soleil du focus avoir
vraiment ça correspond à ce que vous
voulez ce que vous aimez rejoue monde
sur un bout de bois donc c'est pas
forcément hyper évident se rendre compte
mais l'idée c'est de se dire ok vous
êtes créatif vous voulez faire des
vidéos et des regarder on vous donne des
éléments de colorimétrie directement
pour venir shooter comme ça tout ça
c'est marrant alors oui je suis en 4k
hdr rouiller l'associé dans les réglages
sur un 1080p alors moi ce que je veux
c'est du 16 9 4 cas donc ça m'intéresse
et après je peux pousser même en 30
images par seconde et apprécié des
formats et vidéos efficient avec earth
des fichiers un petit peu moins lourd
j'ai une teinte de films avec de
l'intelligence artificielle ok ça peut
être un paradoxe à ce qu'ils ont proposé
la grille de composition mon niveau le
minuteur bravo n'y a pas de petites
options et on peut même se mettre en log
est là en loques ça veut dire quoi saga
qui a filmé en flat c'est à dire que je
vais avoir toutes les informations de
lumières de couleurs dans mon image mais
lorsque je la bois il va paraître
extrêmement plate comme ce qu'on est en
train de filmer tout juste avec le
boîtier juste au dessus mais après enfui
de la colorimétrie donc soit vous filmer
en log vous pouvez ensuite vous
appliquez votre colorimétrie soit vous
venez directement avec un lot ici au
rock je désactive ça et je passe avec le
lot est là avec les notes et bien je
vais avoir un traitement d'imagés
directement dessus donc le truc est
assez marrante l'idée c'est vraiment de
se dire ok on voit qu'aujourd'hui que
les smartphones on peut faire des vidéos
et bien là on vous donne tous les outils
pour le faire en plus du mode vidéo vous
avez vous avez un mode film
truc vachement intéressant au niveau de
la photo c'est que vous savez alors bien
évidemment on a le hardware on a le
matériel on comprendre il ya un gros
travail qui est fait au niveau sauf
temps derrière ils font travailler
notamment ensemble à votre grand angle
et votre contrat grand temple qui vont
bosser ensemble sur une certaine partie
attention pas sur tout et puis vous avez
également votre grand angle et votre
télé objectifs qui vont venir bosser
ensemble sur une certaine partie du loup
l'idée c'est quoi d'ailleurs et bien
l'idée c'est de se dire ok on va
chercher à améliorer et grâce à leur
temps déjà le tas parce qu'il est un
petit peu tordu grâce à de la
photographie computationnelle rien que
ça messieurs dames eh bien ça vous
permet d'avoir une image qui est
complètement optimisé et de meilleure
qualité on dit pas juste de 0,6 jusqu'à
rang et bien je suis en ultra
grand-angle non ça c'est fini maintenant
on prend tout on mélange entre l'espace
de petits melting-pot et ça fonctionne
en tout cas sur le papier et je trouve
ça bien ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on voit ici c'est qu'en fait ces
smartphones c'est à dire des petites
caméras de poche on va pas forcément
prendre tout le temps des boîtiers comme
ça mais vous savez à une époque et bien
le smartphone a commencé à remplacer les
appareils photo les réflexes les bridges
cours trouvait beaucoup une époque
aujourd'hui tout le monde smartphones il
reste quelques amoureux de photos qui
utilisent encore des boîtiers mais de
moins en moins parce que les smartphones
sont devenus extrêmement performant
photos jusqu'à ya pas longtemps le
parent boxe était quand même la vidéo la
vidéo était pas mal comprenez symphonie
plus haut de gamme en échasses plutôt
pas mal mais pas toujours exceptionnel
et là on voit qu'ils cherchent à aller
vers une nouvelle cible d'un des
créateurs de contenu de ceux qui font du
tic toc ceux qui vont du slap shade pas
tout le monde aujourd'hui donc on
améliore significativement la qualité en
vidéo et ça c'est intéressant ça fait
deux très jolies promesses aux
smartphones qui est bien évidemment
certifié ip 68 qui a dû en effet pour le
témoin dématérialisée puis bien
évidemment du wifi 6 et puis un truc que
nous a fait honneur qui est assez
intéressant c'est une techno qui va
empêcher que des personnes autour de
vous puisse entendre vos appels
téléphoniques c'est le point de s'y
coller ces faits à base d'intelligence
artificielle pour que le son soit
vraiment diriger que vers votre oreille
et que ça ne rayonne pas autour et
complice pas entendre vos conversations
extrêmement privée extrêmement important
parce que on a tous coloration comme ça
on n'a pas envie de tourner en tant que
voilà donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant à
voir une fois de plus et à tester pour
voir si ça fonctionne et le prix dans
tout ça me direz vous bien vous avez
raison c'est une question légitime en
version 8 gigas de ram 256 go de
stockage vous êtes un effet
spectaculaire 1099 euros on est au
dessus des 1000 euros chez au nord avec
un honor magic 4 pro intéressant sur le
papier à voir on regardera ça sur le au
nord magic a trôné à 899 donc vous voyez
au nord vient en nous montrant les
muscles on a connu beaucoup au nord en
ayant un positionnement fort dans le
milieu de gamme et là ils attaquent
france vivent plus loin avec ce haut de
gamme c'est intéressant c'est une gamme
qui continue qui s'étoffe qui va plus
loin et au nord s'est séparé il ya pas
longtemps de huawei du groupe à où ils
sont indépendants c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont récupéré les services google et on
le voit qu'ils ont montré l'innovation
avec leur smartphone plia pliant comme
vous voulez qu'ils sont toujours très
forts dans le milieu une progression qui
est assez spectaculaire est intéressant
dans l'ogaden attention attention pense
avec des pincettes parce que ses
smartphones il faut venir les tester il
faut venir les essayé on a une très
jolie présentation mais sans venir se
mettre sur le terrain et puis essayer ça
ça vaut pas grand chose donc c'est bien
simple est cette jolie promesse une fois
de plus le fait qu'il ya un gros taxant
au niveau de la vidéo c'est intéressant
on regardera ça très prochainement donc
rester connecté abonnez vous puissiez
vous avez des questions pour ses
smartphones ou les marques et bien
évidemment juste ans dans un commentaire
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous mais
nous on va aller profiter de barcelone
bon il ya encore beaucoup de travail
donc pas plus tard le port les cocktails
fond d'alcool bref la fête vous embrasse
fort match
[Musique]